parce que cette image du dragon et
l'autruche est toujours à l'ordre du
jour parce que côté chinois on vient
chercher des matières premières en
afrique et côté africain on cherche
évidemment des désinvestissements à des
infrastructures est ce que ça résume
bien l'intérêt mutuel des deux pays y
compris d'ailleurs à l'échelon parce que
ça résume bien finalement la relation
afrique chine absolument vous savez
c'est une relation qui est bâti sur
des intérêts disons en apparence
convergent la chine a besoin non
seulement des matières premières mais
les marchés des infrastructures mais
également d'un espace pour déployer son
ou voir d'où son soft power afin de
gagner les voix africaines voix qui lui
ont été très utiles dans son évolution
souvenez vous le 25 octobre 1971 dans la
chine a retrouvé la chine continentale
le siège qu'occupait taiwan à
l'assemblée générale de l'onu et au
conseil de sécurité après la guerre
civile chinoise
1946 à 1949 dans la chine a le plus
baissé ce siège c'est grâce aux voix
africaines donc la chine clairement à v
un intérêt a toujours un mais télé a
déployé sa stratégie de pouvoir en
afrique de l'eau du coq et le pays
africains que les ressources naturelles
qui ont marché qui ont des possibilités
à offrir à des partenaires et qui
veulent chercher à diversifier leur
partenariat pour ne pas être seulement
tributaires de leurs anciennes
puissances coloniales ou des états unis
évidemment voyez en la chine ce
partenaire qui voulait la nouvelle foire
est toujours très bien dans votre pays
au sénégal par exemple il ya un an le
secteur de la cacahuète a été a subi une
forte demande chinoise qu'est ce qui a
provoqué des tensions des manifestations
la chine est devenue le premier
importateur de cacahuètes dans votre
pays dans quelle mesure
c'est difficile finalement de canaliser
les appétits chinois sur le continent
vous savez la chine ces deux pays d'1
milliard 300 millions d'habitants ou
plus pour quand elle s'intéresse un
produit ou un marché elle rafle tout et
donc ça change les dom c'est ce qu'on
appelle
une disruption quand elle intervient
dans des pays surtout les petits pays
comme le sénégal ces deux cent mille
kilomètres carrés c'est une population
de 15 millions d'habitants donc pour les
agriculteurs qui font leur chic voir la
chine arrivé à priori c'est un atout
parce que le coût que les chinois sont
disposés à pays pour preuve cette
matière première l'arachide ou allait
enfin aux choses structurer sa mêmes
vite dit c'est un enfer du lait qui le
vendent en afrique naturellement c'est
tentant
[Musique]